if there's someone that's very very
young who might be really religious and
like values marriage a lot and goes into
a marriage and has kids when they're
like 18 19 20 and then
um a year into the relationship it gets
really really
from both anyone anyone really
I'm just yeah even though it might be
rare from what you guys think
if it would happen what would you
recommend for those people to do will
they divorce or do you want them to keep
going in the relationship going you
can't divorce I mean that's not a real
thing uh you can like separate see his
Catholic background shines through he
knows
you can separate but you can't actually
divorce that's not a real thing even
though it might be like physically
abusive you got to endure people are too
you want to stick
are just [__] everybody [__] quits
hahaha
well if you're looking for me I'll be in
my home space over here but you're not
you're not willing to endure this
yeah I'm the four I'm divorcing this
subject
so you have to endure I understand the
sentiment that people feel like folks
divorce too easily and for the wrong
reasons okay I understand and I can even
get behind that sentiment to a degree
but also people marry for the wrong
reason and too easily but go ahead I'm
sorry I was gonna say
uh beating your wife is a good reason
for a divorce
I I like you can say okay well I stuck
through it and we figured out and maybe
you have but expecting other people who
again they asked me to stay in a
marriage where they're getting beaten up
is crazy indoor people quit too now
easily nowadays what that's your
response to somebody who's being
physically beaten by their partner you
know they sit here and they talk about
single parent households this single
parent households that do you think it's
good to raise a child in a violent
environment that's even worse there's
some relationship you talk about it's
bad to be single there's some people
that are still together and has been
been a detrimental kids why be because
it was a toxic environment but whatever
I'll even say this I think it's far
worse to grow up in an environment where
your dad beats your mom on a regular
basis or he beats the kids or they she
beats him whatever it might be that's
worry worse than growing up in a single
parent household I wouldn't even
consider the two in the same ballpark
you have to understand okay I hate
bringing this up because people make it
a bigger deal than this but then you
have these retards who get on podcasts
and proudly say you you should endure
you should endure you do realize that
most of the people who die in
relationships as a result of spousal
violence are women right so how do you
expect any of your movements to be taken
seriously and to not be seen as
anti-woman when your advice to women who
are being beaten up by their Partners is
to endure everybody [__] quits
everybody gives up it's too hard I'm
this XYZ this is why I'm special so I
can [__] up this entire situation or
maybe
the person who [__] up and gave up is
the person who beat their partner
is that not a possibility to me
personally the person who decides to lay
their hands on the person they're
supposed to protect to their dying
breath is probably the deadbeat loser
who gave up on the relationship but
maybe that's a hot take maybe I'm the
[__] and all this I'll tell you what
indoors I'll tell you what I would do
if if my daughter was in a relationship
with a guy and she gets married to him
and he starts abusing her you're into it
no no no no no no no no no no wait wait
no no no no no time now smack time out
time out what the [__]
no way there's no way time out so when
is your daughter kill him no she
shouldn't do her
but when there's other people they
shouldn't get divorced
so if your arms so you see how they have
different rules for the women in their
lives but for the women at General that
they're not connected to who they don't
have to have any empathy for they're
saying endure cards man says oh no but
if it's your daughter you're going to
murder her
this is the time when conservatives just
sound [__] okay and this is the time
where they have you know how the left of
the people this is their retardation and
the reality is people just haven't
learned to [__] endure there have
been hard times in a relationship I'm
sure you guys had Hard Times
relationship any relationship has a hard
time and it is what it is you need to
push through hard times is such a
general thing so it's like there's a
difference between you guys are going
through financial struggles and you've
given your girl black eyes because you
don't like your job I mean like there's
a difference between those two things
yeah yeah me and me preach we've been
struggling through things oh yeah uh
preach been stealing from my bank
account every month that's a different
kind of endure
you know what I'm saying what you're
looking at me for
don't put [__] on me I haven't done I
never said you did I'm giving
hypothetical there's a difference
between us going through things
financially because the business not
doing well and you stealing money
someone looking at me because you stole
money and saying adore I'm like [__]
who are you talking to but even if even
if I stole money uh-huh
but push through
do you know how quick this channel would
be over if I find out you saw a whole
substantial amount of money I would
never live with myself doing that to you
same thing exactly same thing but I'm
gonna have to stress that I'm never
having to worry about but it matters but
you stole money it's not even the money
because you know me money not that deep
to me is a principle but endure like we
got a good no but bro we got a good
thing going on I'm sitting here thinking
like it's just money so exactly you
could have just asked me I'd have given
you the cash but yo it's just okay okay
so what's the problem
endure because what we're in this
situation now like where everybody's
just creating this like super nuanced
like one percent example of like well
what if the kids [__] super new ones
were like do you think
do you think spousal what wait do you
think spouse would like a one percent
thing you'll play foreign
it's not that rare you talk about she
went if the relationship is abusing what
do they do nearly 20 of marriages and
intimate Partnerships will experience
physical violence according to the
American Association of marriage and
family therapy let's say it's not twenty
percent ten percent I still a lot like I
think if you guys look into your lives I
don't know about y'all but me personally
I think most of us can say that we've
known somebody who's been in an abusive
relationship or marriage
I know several relationships for sure
marriage a few only
it's not that uncommon and there's a lot
of Shame and hush hushness associated
with that you probably got family
members who are married to somebody who
beat them but didn't want to talk about
it publicly
they won't because you're going to tell
them to pursue yes
oh hi
yeah
you know summer is coming out and things
are going to be pretty hot for your skin
and you don't want to use anything
that's going to be able to
you know ouch
there's gonna be able to hurt your skin
you want something soft you know what I
mean
come here
that's why Tas Henley has the product
for you yeah you do not want to use some
abrasive stuff on your skin some of your
are degenerate soap from the dishwasher
the washing nooks and crannies come on
pass on baby
summer has come in if you don't know
what to do with your skin I would
suggest you to use the level one box
yeah there's a bunch of stuff a scrub to
get in the nooks and crannies to get all
the little residue out you know there's
a daily facial wash there's also an AM
moisturizer with SPF 15 no it's SPS 20
for the sun yeah use them promo pH
Henley use that thing it's really great
it's for your skin and it's soft
and
since the wonderful weather is coming
you do want to be able to use that and I
have a wonderful skin yeah hmm thank you
for that if you click on the link below
you will not only save 30 off your first
box but you will also receive a gift and
get your skin ready for summer you know
yeah
well that started how about you
like cool
cool unfucking [__] mind you my new
situation
what would you recommend okay
this is repeat the word it's crazy so
doctor uh so I have to explain my endure
indoor okay you're being a [__] right
now two Tylenols a glass of water go to
sleep indoor okay it's normal yeah I got
a whole kidney infection if it's normal
you're in pain right yeah and then
people think that we're going nuclear
with this [__] like with the the
painting in the doctor yeah but it's an
illness it's a problem that you have in
your butt it's a bit the same thing with
a relationship when something like that
is happening and going on it can affect
the rest of your body it act it things
like that can actually and I'm talking
about just not physical but verbal abuse
that affects your body there's plenty of
things your partner can say to you that
you wish you would have just punched you
for
and I think you guys can think about
what's the worst thing your partner can
tell you in terms of insecurities or
that would be hurtful to you but even
your friends yeah I've seen men broken
by conversations at dinner tables when a
woman said something too much about her
man or a man said something like this
[__] gonna be toxic tonight you should
have just slapped her because I probably
would have got over a bit better but
shout out to you will
[Music]
you just brought a Will Smith
but
but okay okay okay
Petty yes but I'm gonna be showing up on
their doorstep and teaching him some
lessons that's that's what I would do I
also would not if if if I didn't have
the you know capacity to do that for
some reason I don't know I wouldn't want
my daughter in that situation quite
frankly and I understand the argument to
endure because I have people close to me
who grew up in abusive households and it
lasted for periods of time and it was a
phase and they endured through it and
they ended up raising healthy successful
families what about if uh two people get
married
and then the wife starts cheating do you
think they should divorce
himself said in cases of adultery
divorces do you think the divorce is
worse than physical abuse well because
she got him there she got him there all
this time they're Catholics right yeah
oh well whoa whoa whoa whoa some of them
are Catholics you know what I mean they
wear it as a badge to be able to say yes
yes yes yes their behavior and what they
actually advocate for in other areas not
sure it's all Catholic but anyways you
notice the whole endure thing goes right
out the window and it's cheating you can
beat your partner work it out but if
they cheat on you it's a wrap
your sister okay was like or somebody in
your life was in the relationship or a
marriage and you found out they were
being cheated on you'd probably be upset
if you found out they were getting their
ass beaten wouldn't you have a
completely different reaction which one
would you be like I'm a killer like
cheating is a thing that happens don't
endure it get out of the relationship
fine but your loved one is beating
beaten
then the guy the guy goes to the girl
y'all what up baby girl
so
would you rather me cheating on you or
beating the [__] out of you
choose because it's happening now
oh no man this is crazy to me that these
guys are just sitting here like side
dick unacceptable but side punches are
fine
hey I don't know to me it's just crazy
people are [__]
fight they don't
what about cheating no Gotta Go Gotta Go
She Gotta Go Gotta Go She Gotta Go
what happened to your endure philosophy
what happened
I guess your emotions are more important
than her physical body
I like the fact that
I like the fact that they always talk
about enjoying like back in the day
people used to enjoy
like
yeah they did
but it's not because they had choice
they didn't have a choice
so they endure and they that make him
better not really
there's a lot of people that endured
remember here in Quebec in Quebec uh
back then they used to tell women that
they had to have church kids and kids
and kids and kids and kids that's what
they were supposed to do children that
was some of these women more than we'd
like to like of these women to you you'd
say yeah it's just a little percentile
but morning we couldn't have
14 16 17 kids but they had to do it
because the Catholic Church said you
know what you have to endure and push
more babies and the lady couldn't and
what happened
death and then a man was supposed to
raise 17 kids
with the oldest trying to do the best to
yeah they endured
they did enjoy it doesn't necessarily
make it better or it doesn't mean that
it's a good thing they used to do it
back then yeah look at the ramification
of that look around the ramification of
things and people enduring I don't know
that makes up for very miserable people
but then again you said there are
Catholics oh I get it nothing again kept
nothing against Catholics but I don't
know it's just very square and it's it's
I don't know it's a bit frightening just
just knowing that these people are
influencing so many people and some of
the stuff that they're saying to young
men it's like yeah you're a woman she
should endure you beating her
that's the dumbest [__] I've heard today
congratulations guys like these people
might be the result or might be the
people who like sanction you know folks
end up beating people just like oh
endure it tolerate it how about the
advice stick to this
if you beat your partner you're a
garbage ass person and you might need
some therapy to fix your own [__]
issues how about focusing on that end
and not expecting women okay okay the
ones who overwhelm me take the brunt of
it and the worst ends of it to just sit
there and be punching bags for men who
haven't dealt with their [__] issues
how about not putting kids through those
kinds of environment come on just a
thought
that is it for today's video let us know
what you guys think were you guys able
to enjoy all this with us if you are now
you're ready for an abusive relationship
congratulations anything else no no all
right